[موسيقى]
طب توم وطبته اوقاتكم مع اهلا بكم الى
اخبار الساعه وهذه ابرز عناوينها
قيوده طالبان ضد المراه تهدد بكارثه في
افغانستان الملايين يواجهون خطر البقاء
والتعلم على شفا الانهيار
بعدها اللقاء موسكو ولا بوادر التقارب
التركيه مع دمشق هديه ثمينه في شمال
السوريه واوعود على الطريق
وفاته اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه بيليه
عن 82 عاما بسرطان القولون
خلقتهم فلسطينيين من حكومتنه اليمنيه
اولوياتها توسيع الاستيطان التهجير واعاده
الاغتيالات
العالم يودع عام 2022 بازمه طاقه غير
مسبوقه وارتفاع كبير في الاسعار هل
ستفرغ السنه الجديده 2023 ايضا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم طالبان وضعت افغانستان على شفا
كارثه انسانيه فبقررها منع المراه من
التعليم الجامعي لم توجه طالبان ضربه
لحقوق المراه فحسن بل وضعت كل قطاع
التعليم الجامعي في خطر الامر كذلك
بالنسبه لمنع عمل النساء في المنظمات
الانسانيه الحركه هددت بذلك حياه شعب كامل
يعيش اغلبه على المساعدات للبقاء على قيد
الحياه الامر لم يعد يتوقف على المراه بل
المجتمع باكمله
في التحركات الداخليه بينما التسعه دائره
الاستقالات الاساتذه الجامعيين ترد على
قرار طالبان زادت ايضا نسبه الطلاب
المقاطعين للمحاضرات للامتحانات تضامنا مع
زميلاتهم
فيما اغلقت جامعات ابوابها بالكامل بينها
جامعه مورا في كابول وباتت ربع الجامعات
الخاصه في افغانستان تواجه خطر الاغلاق
والافلاس بسبب الحظر المقروطي على
الطالبات المتحدث باسم اتحاد الجامعات
الخاصه قال ان 35 مؤسسه تعليميه معرضه
للاغلاق
يوجد في افغانستان 140 جامعه خاصه في 24
مقاطعه تضم حوالي 200000 طالب بينهم نحو
70,000 طالب
الجامعات حوالي خمس 25,000 شخص هؤلاء
مهددون بخسارتي وظائفهم الان
[موسيقى]
واضمن ردود الفعل الدوليه على
وزراء خارجيه دول لمجموعه السابعه طالبان
الى الغاء قرار منع عمل للنساء في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه فورا فاصفين في
بيان قرار الحركه في انه متهور وخطير
ويعرض ملايين الافغان للقطر من جانبها
حضرت وكالات واغاثه كبرى ان مواطنين افغان
سيموتون اذا لم تعود المنظمات للعمل خصوصا
وان افغانستان
الجوع في التاريخ وفقا المنظمات
من جانبه قال منسقه للامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه في افغانستان انه لجنه الطوارئ
سترسل وفد الرفيعه المستوى من اجل اقناع
طالبا بالتراجع عن قراراتها التي تقيد
حريه المراه في افغانستان
للامم المتحده بزياره الى افغانستان
القادمه
التعاون الاسلاميه الحسين طاهر ابراهيم
مجمع الفقه الاسلامي الدولي لحشدي موقفه
مشترك من كافه المرجعيات الاسلاميه
والعلماء يدين قرار طالبان لمنع الفتيات
من التعليم وتداعيه
[موسيقى]
اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه بلا يفارق
الحياه خبر حزين تلقاه عشاق كره القدم
العالميه والبرازيليه على وجه الخصوص
برحيل احد اعظم لاعبي كره القدم عبر
التاريخ توفي نجم البرازيليه عن عمر نهز
88 عاما بعد صراع طويل مع المرض وقد اشار
تقرير طبي برازيلي ان سبب وفاه بيليه هو
فشلوا اعضاء متعدده
ناتج عن سرطان القولون وحظيه بلاء الملقب
بالجوهره السوداء بمسيره كبيره في كره
القدم توجه خلال هذه ثلاث بطولات كاس عالم
في عام
1962 و 1970
[موسيقى]
معنى من عمان المحلل الرياضي معتصم يونسيد
يونس اهلا بك لم يعد السؤال
مارادونا رحل مارادونا ولا حقه بيليه ولكن
اليوم نتحدث هل بليه هو اسطوره كره القدم
لن تنجب الملاعب
في البرازيل او غيرها
مساء الخير عزيزي عادل تحيه لك وكل
الزملاء الكرام في قناه العربيه فرصه
سعيده وفي ذلك الوقت ايضا فرص فرصه حزينه
تواجد اليوم في 29
ديسمبر بوفاه احد عمدان كره القدم على
مدار تاريخها الاسطوره البرازيلي بيليه
بكل تاكيد لا يمكن الحديث في الوقت الرهن
من هو الافضل انه هناك اجماع بانه كان
لاعب القرن في الفتره الماضيه وحتى
بشهاده من خصمه وغريمه اللدود بالنسبه
لمارادونا برغم من انهم في الاجيال مختلفه
ولكن في الفتره في الفتره التي كان بها
البرازيلي بليه يصول ويجول في عالم كره
القدم كان اسطوره كان اعجوبه لم يكن احد
ليصدق ماذا يقدم هذا الفتى الذي راى النور
في ملاعب كره القدم في السادس عشر من عمره
الجوهره السمراء كان يتميز بثلاثه بسرعه
عاليه لكن يمتلك مهاره لكن يمتلك اسلوب
خاص متفرد يجعل كل من يشاهده في حيره بانه
ظهر قبل مونديال 58 عام المنتخب ورازيل
يحصد برفقتهم كاس العالم ومن ثم يحقق ايضا
لقب اللقب الذي اا يليه 62 وحتى لقب 70
وحتى قيل انه في مونديال 66 لم يكن في
افضل احوال المدنيه كان يعامل اصابه لو
كان موجود لكان السهم ايضا في تحقيق اربعه
كؤوس عالم وليس ثلاثه فقط للمنتخب
البرازيلي انا بالنسبه لي لا يمكن لي في
الوقت هذا الحديث هل كان هو الافضل على مر
العصور ولكن هناك اجماع كبير بان لا يتكرر
البرازيل ولا في عالم كره القدم العالميه
معتصم ما الذي ميز به يعني البعض يقول من
انا مارادونا ربما قدم فنيات وصنع
للارجنتين همم ما لم يصنعه باليه كان
برفقه نجوم هل بلى بعمره الصغير وحصله
ثلاثه القاب لكاس العالم هو ما يميزه
عين الحقيقه تخيل في السادسه والعشاء في
السادس هو في السادسه عشر من عمرك وتلعب
مع الفريق الاول برفقه اساطير في عالم كره
القدم البرازيل
وتعلم ما يسمى بمنتخب السحره
زيكو الكثير من الاسماء المهريه ولكن هذا
اللاعب كان يظهرهم في السن ولكن كان
اكثرهم موهبه كان اكثرهم رشاقه سرعه
القدره كره القدم في عهد كانت اصعب بكثير
من ما كانت عليه الاله اي نعم تحدثه بان
الاهداف في الالف التي كانت في عصر ما قبل
ما يسمى بقانون التسلل في العالم قد قدم
يكون هناك اجماع بحجم المهاره بحجم
الموهبه بحجم الاتقان بحجم الفنيات
الرائعه في العالم لكره القدم التقييم في
مدح بيليه قالوا شاهدنا الكثير من المواهب
الكثير من الراقصين من السحره في مختلف
الاحياء ومختلف الشوارع والمنتخب
البرازيلي على مر العصور ولكن كمليه لم
نشاهد احد اينعم الكثيرون في الوقت الراي
لم يشاهدوا بلال في فتره الخمسينات
والستينات ولكن ليه لا يزال يقارن بنجوم
حاليين الجهه المطر تقرب بمقام به بلا
وحتى ما ردوا لا يقرب ليونيل ميسي الافضل
حاليا في هذه
الحلقه بامكانيه ولكن لا يتكرر بلا ليه
برازيلي اي بما معناها الموهبه الصافي
الموهبه الربانيه وانت تعلم جيدا بان
البرازيل لطالما خرجت الكثير من الراعي
والكثير من الصحراء ولكن بلاي يتقدمم
والان وليس له شرعي في قياده السلسه وهو
نيمار جونيور ولكن
همم شكرا جزيلا للمحلل الرياضيه معتصم
يونس من عمان
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
بعد وابل القصف الروسي على كيف الاتحاد
الاوروبيه تواعد بالرد على جرائم الحرب
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله بدات بوادر التقارب التركيه مع
دمشق تظهر بعدها يوم من اول لقاء الجماعه
ووزراء دفاع سوريا وتركيا وروسيا في موسكو
عمان تركيا قدمت ما يعتبره البعض تنازلات
للنظام الاسد او كما وصفها اخرون هدايا
على حساب الاكراد كما ما هدت الطريقه
للقاءات وشيكه وابرام اتفاقيه وزير
الخارجيه التركيه مولود اكد استعداد انقره
لنقل السيطره بمناطق وجودها في سوريا الى
دمشق في حاله تحقيق الاستقرار السياسي
وهنا طبعا نتحدث عن مناطق الشمال السوري
قال مولود ان تركيا ترغب بعوده اللاجئين
السوريين وتعمل على تامين ذلك واشار الى
ان هذه الملفات ستطرح في لقاء غريب سيجمعه
مع نظيره السوري فيصل المقداد
الى تطبيق القرار الامامي
2154 بشان الحالي في سوريا
[موسيقى]
وعن اولي تعليقنا كرديه سوري على التطورات
بين انقره ونظام الاسد برعايه الروسيه
اعتبرت الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه في شمال
شرق سوريا ان اللقاء يهدف لترسيليا اقدام
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وحزبه في
السلطه قبل الانتخابات التركيه القادمه
وان هذه اللقاء ستتطور لمرحله جديده من
الصفقات والخطه المعاديه لمصالح السوريين
والسعيد لاحياء اتفاقيه اضمه التي كانت
مضحكه وجائره بحق الشعوب المنطقه كما طلبت
الاداره كلا من روسيا والنظام السوري
بالكشف عن فحوى هذه اللقاءات الامنيه
والعسكريه بعد 12 عاما من العداء
والاحتلال والتدمير في سوريا التي تعيش
اوضاعا ماساويه
انه عام التحولات في السياسه التركيه جمله
من المتغيرات في ثوابت انقره السياسيه
والثابت الوحيد في منظور تركيا
لاعداء دائما في السياسه تركيا مستعده
لنقل السيطره من مناطق تواجدها الى النظام
حال استعاده الاستقرار السياسي وعوده
الامور الى طبيعتها في البلاد هو تصريح
لوزير الخارجيه مولود شاويش اوغلو في
تعليقه على تقاربه بلاده مع دمشق
بلاده مع النظام السوري ستمهد لحل سياسيا
وفق قرارات الامم المتحده يضمن عوده امنه
للاجئين مؤكدا استمرار تلك الاتصالات
المتحده وروسيا والعراق والنظام السوري
مستمره
تقارب انقره مع دمشق تمخض عنه لقائه وزراء
دفاع تركيا وسوريا وروسيا في موسكو بحضور
رؤساء مخابرات الدول الثلاث كاول لقاء
الرسمي بين مسؤولين اتراك وسوريين منذ 11
عاما
في اطار قرار مجلس الامن رقم 22 54 وبهذا
المعنى فاننا نعتبر ان الاعمال التي سيتم
تنفيذها في الايام المقبله
ستساهم بشكل جيد في احلال السلام
والاستقرار في المنطقه وسوريا
المسلحون الاكراد في صلب مفاوضات دمشق
وانقره وجودهم قرب الحدود يؤرق تركيا التي
هددت بشان عمل عسكري يستهدف مناطقهم المهم
بالنسبه لتركيا خلال الفتره الحاليه هو
ابعاد الخطر الكردي عن حدودها هناك خطوه
اخرى متعلقه باللاجئين خط على عنها الرئيس
اردوغان قبل اشهر وهي التفاهم باعاده
هؤلاء اللاجئين الى سوريا قبل الاقدام على
الانتخابات
العامل الداخليه هو الفيصل والدافع الرئيس
لانقرا في تقاربها السريع مع دمشق وفق
محللين فورقه اللاجئين التي تشهرها
المعارضه في وجه اردوغان باتت تشكل تهديدا
لمستقبله ومساعده في كسب الانتخابات
التاليه
دائما في السياسه باتع عنوانا
الاستراتيجيه الرئيس التركي خلال الفتره
الماضيه وكما يرى البعض ان كل الخطوات
السياسيه خلال العام الجاري والاشهر
القادمه انما تهدف الى ابعاد الناخبين عن
صناديق المعارضه وجذب الاصوات الى
الاعتناء في الحاكم زيدان زنجلو العربيه
اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
في اسرائيل لا اكتملت عوده رئيس الوزراء
المكلف بنيامين نتنياهو الى سده الحكم من
خلال عرض حكومته الجديده حكومه سرقت
الانظره حتى قبل تعليم هذا العديد من
المصادر تصفها بالحكومه الاكثر تشددا في
تاريخ اسرائيل ماذا تحمل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده
للفلسطينيين سؤال لا تبعث الاجابه عليه
بالتفاؤل الكبير ملف شائك سيكون مصدر توتر
جديد بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين وهو
ملف توسيع المستوطنات
اولوياته توسيع المستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه بل ايضا الشرعيه على عشرات
الاستيطانيه كما نتوسع يشمل الجليل
والنقاب والمرتفعات الجولان والضفه
الغربيه
توسيع المستوطنات لا يثير حفيظه
الفلسطينيين فحسب معظم المجتمع الدولي بما
في ذلك الولايات المتحده وهو ما جاء على
لسان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكل الذي وعد بمواصله معارضه الاستيطان
الاسرائيلي او ضم الاراضي في الضفه
الغربيه السلطه الفلسطينيه من جهتها ردت
على خطه نتنياهو في توسيع المستوطنات حيث
ادانا نبيل ابو ردينه المتحدث باسم الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس ادام الخطوط العريضه
للحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده معتبرا ذلك
تصعيدا خطيره ستكون له تداعيات على
المنطقه
بتخيوط
[موسيقى]
معنا من رام الله محمد الحوراني عضو
المجلس الثوري الي حركه فتح اهلا بك سيد
محمد
هذه حكومه بالفعل كما قال حتى اصدقاء
اسرائيل في امريكا تعتبر اخطر حكومه منذ
تاسيس دوله الاحتلال منذ عام 48 هذا مرض
ايضا على الحكومه
على جانس وزير الدفاع الاسبق يعلنون اذا
نحن امام حكومه
ستدفع الامور باتجاه التفجير لسبب ان
المفاوضات التي حصلت من اجل التشكيل هذا
الاتلاف تضمنت سلفا خطوات عمليه منها
تشييع 30 مستوطنه منها فرض السياده
الاسرائيليه على كل فلسطين التاريخيه اي
انهاء عملي ونهاء بشكل رسمي
لاي احتمال اي مسار سياسي طبعا هذه
الحكومه اليوم اعلى من ثلاث محاور محور
يتعلق بايران محور يتعلق بالدنيا التحتيه
والاقتصاد الاسرائيلي طبعا جزء من البنيه
التحتيه سيكون توسيع الاستيطان ومصادره
المزيد من ولا المحور الثالث السلام مع
العالم العربي اي ليس مع الفلسطينيين
كاننا ليسوا موجودين
وتتطلع هذه الحكومه على موضوع السلام
الابراهيمي لعقد مزيد من الاتفاقيات
وتنكر الفلسطينيين في نفس الوقت
كيف سيؤثر ذلك على الداخل الفلسطيني هل
همم تم تحركات قادمه
الشعب الفلسطيني على الارض يقاوم يدافع عن
كل شارع عن كل بيت عن كل حجر ولكن هو الان
بحاجه اولا ان يكف المجتمع الدولي على
استمرار النفاق لدوله احتلال تمارس كل هذا
ضد شعب اعزل وتعلن بشكل رسمي اليوم في اول
بنك من بنود الاحتلاف ان اسرائيل هواد
الحكومه
ستفرض السياده الاسرائيلي على كل اراضي
فلسطين التاريخيه
وتترك اختيار الوسيله والوقت المناسب اخدا
بعين الاعتبار اللي هو المعطيات الدوليه
المعطيات الدوليه بالنسبه له انه يريد ان
يمارس هذا الامر بالتدريج وكما قلت ان هو
النقطه الثالثه الاستمرار في عمليات
التطبيق والسلام مع دول قله خرطت في
السلام الابراهيمي هذا يطرح سؤال يتعلق
بالمناسبه بالامن القومي العربي قضيه
فلسطين
في نعم هدينا هي جزء من هذا الامن الذي لا
يتجزا يعني لا نتوقف مع الرد لا ملكيه على
حكومه نتنياهو ونعود اليك بعد قليل الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن اكد انه يتطلع للعمل مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده برئاسه
بنيامين نتنياهو لتعزيز المصالح المشتركه
بيض قال ان واشنطن ستواصل دعم حل للدولتين
وستعارض اي سياسه تهددها هذا المبدا
والعمل معنا في نياهو على جهود السلام مع
الفلسطينيين كما اكد الرئيس الامريكي ان
الاداره الامريكيه ستواصل ايضا العمل
معانيه ضد التهديدات الايرانيه في المنطقه
معنى من رام الله محمد الحوراني عضو مجلسا
ثوري لحركه فتح السيد محمد يعني هذا الرد
الامريكي كيف تقراه على ارض الواقع
هو هذا اعلان ولكن السؤال يتعلق بالاداره
الامريكيه هل ستنفذ اي خطوه سياسيه ضاغط
على اسرائيل من اجل هذا الاعلان هي كانت
قد اعلنت مثلا عند فوز انها ستعيد مثلا
فتح القنصليه الامريكيه التي كانت مفتوحه
منذ القرن التاسع عشر وكانت تقديم
الفلسطينيين في القدس الشرقيه حتى الان لم
تقدم على هذه الخطوه قالت انها ستعيد فتح
السفاره الفلسطينيه في او المكتب التمثيل
الفلسطيني في واشنطن لم تقدم على ذلك احنا
نرى ان كل اعلانات الاداره الامريكيه اللي
احنا يعني نقول عنها جيده ولكن اين
التنفيذ ليس اليوم انما منذ ان بدا عملها
لذلك نعتقد انه فيما يتعلق باعلان ان كان
الرئيس او وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انه هو
يرفض الاستيطان هذا رفض ربما للعلاقات
العامله لان هذه ماضيه في تنفيذ سياستها
ان كان سابقا وان كان اليوم المطلوب الان
بصراحه المجتمع الدولي واطراف اخرى تدخل
لتعزل اسرائيل كدوله عنصريه والمطلوب من
بعض والعالم العربي انت راجع افكارها فيما
يتعلق بقدرته على التاثير على اسرائيل
بالحوار اسرائيل تحكم الان من قبل جهات
ايدولوجيه تحكمها خرافات ولا تحترم لا اي
مسار سياسي ولا حتى المجتمع الدولي ولا
القانون الدولي طبعا شكرا يا سيد محمد
الحوراني
حركه فتح من رام الله
[موسيقى]
بعيدا عن ملف في توسيع المستوطنات
والملفات الداخليه الاخرى فان الاولويه
بالنسبه لحكومه 30 ياهو لن تكون سوا
مواجهه ايران رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ترك
جانبا كل القضايا واعطل الاولويه لمواجهه
الخطر الايراني العنوان الرئيسي في خطابه
كانه من ايران من ان تصبح دوله نوويه
[موسيقى]
روسيا تمطر اوكرانيا بوابل من الصواريخ في
هجوم ضخمه استهدف مناطق متفرقه من البلاد
بما فيها العاصمه كيف 120 هو عدد الصواريخ
التي استهدفت اوكرانيا والتاكيد جاء نقلا
عن مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني ميخايلو
بوتوليات الى ذلك نجحت قوه الدفاع الجوي
الاوكرانيه واعلن عن نجاحها في التصدي ل
54 صاروخا الهجمه التي استهدفت محطات
الطاقه ايضا
ادت الى انقطاع الكهرباء في الكثير من
الاجواء من بينها العاصمه كيبما الدال
انقطاع الكهرباء عن 40% من المستهلكين في
المدينه
[موسيقى]
64 صاروخ دمر الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني منها
54 صاروخا بالنسبه بلغ الثمانيه
بالمئه وهي نسبه اعتبرها القائد العام
للقوات المسلحه الاخرانيه
الابواب خلعت الان نفكر فيما يمكننا ان
نفعله المنزل بارد جدا ويجب ان نجد حالا
عندما حدث ذلك اخذت الطفل بسرعه الى القبو
حدث انفجارين لقد كان ذلك امورعبا كنت
خائفا على الاطفال كان نصيب العاصمه من
القصف الروسي صباح اليوم 16 صاروخا
اسقطتها جميعا انظمه دفاع المدينه الا ان
بعض الشظايا طالت بعض احيائها على غرار
دار مسكين وبتشيرسكي بينما سقطت قديفه على
قريه
دمارا كبيرا حيث اقف الان جميع المباني
المحيطه دمر بشكل كامل او جزئي كما اصيب
ثلاثه اشخاص ونقلوا لتلقي الرعايه الصحيه
ويواصل عمال الانقاذ رفع الانقاذ والبحث
عن الضحى
لقد سقطت هنا قذيفه واصيبت امراه واخذوها
الى المستشفى لاجراء عمليه وهناك طفله في
الرابعه عشره من عمرها اصيبت ايضا وجميع
المنازل تضررت
الاستهداف الروسي وكان واسعا نطاق فطال
مدينه ميكا لايف واوديسا في الجنوب
وخاركيف وسومي وبلطافا في الشرق وشرميها
في الشمال وحتى اقصى الغرب الاوكراني
مدينه الفيف لم تسلم فتسعون بالمائه من
المدينه دون كهرباء او مياه 140 بالمئه من
كيف على ذات الحال ومعظم مدن اوكرانيا
تعاني من فقدان هذه الخدمات الاساسيه
نتيجه هذا القصف كيف عادل العربيه العربيه
تحذيرا شديدا لهجه لروسيا متواعده في
تغريده له بان جرائم الحرب التي تتفيضها
روسيا في اوكرانيا لن تمر دون حساب على حد
قوله كما اكد بريل لان الدعم الاوروبي
لاوكانيا سيظل مستمرا
بمنتهى القوه
مجله نيوز ويكا سلطه الدور على تصعيد
الروسي والاسباب خلفيه وان موسكو عادت
لتكثيفها هجماتها العسكريه من خلال الضغط
على شرق وجنوب اوكرانيا
وذكرت صحيفه ان روسيا تواجه مشكله حقيقيه
تتمركز حول نفادي مخزون صواريخها وتسالت
الصحيفه عما اذا كانت روسيا قادره على
مواصله موجات الضربات على المدى الطويل في
حال لم تجد امدادات جديده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
قريبا نودعوا العام 2022 عام الحروب
والصراعات وازمه الطاقه وغداء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لا خلاف على ان ازمه الطاقه كانت
من بين العناوين البارزه التي تصدرت
المشهد بشكل كبير هذا العام اندلاع الحرب
في اوكرانيا واشتداد الصراع بين روسيا
والمعسكر الغربي ادى الى ازمه طاقه حقيقيه
الصراع بين المعسرين تسبب في شحح امدادات
الغاز والنفط ما ادى الى ارتفاع الاسعار
في الاسواق العالميه تطورات ادت الى وصول
سعر الغاز عالميا الى رقم قياسي عند 345
يورو لكل ميجاوات
كما شهد العام 2022 دخول السوق العالميه
للحبوب ازمه حقيقيه ايضا فقد ادت الحرب
الاوكرانيه الى توقف عمليات تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه ما اثر على السوق العالمي
وتسبب بازمه غذاء على مستوى العالم
ارتفاعه اسعار الطاقه فضلا عن ازمه الغذاء
والتضخم وارتفاع الاسعار فجرت موجه
تتظاهره واضطرابات في الكثير من دول
العالم خصوصا اوروبا التي دفعت فاتوره
باهضه احتجاجات طالبت برفع الاجور ونددت
بارتفاع الاسعار في بريطانيا مثلا تشهد
البلاد حتى الان سلسله اضرابات تاريخيه
شملت اربع قطاعات حيويه في البلاد وهي
الصحه التعليم النقل والمؤسسات الحكوميه
كما شاهدت البلاد لاول مره في تاريخها
اضرابا لنقابات التمريض شارك فيه 300,000
ممرض وممرضه في عمومي بريطانيا طبعا
شهدت فرنسا ايضا اضرابات وقبل قليل شهد
قطاع الطيران في بلجيكا شيلنا بعد اضراب
لموظفي شرطه راين اير
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من باريس حسين قنيبر مراسل
العربيه وكذلك مصطفى زارو من لندن ابدا مع
مصطفى مصطفى ما هو الوضع لديك في بريطانيا
واستمرار هذه الاحتجاجات يبدو ان اليومين
الاخيرين في هذا العام لن يمر بسلام
هكذا يبدو الامر عادل ولا مؤشره على نهايه
هذه الاضطرابات والاضطرابات
في مختلف القطاعات لربما سنشهد المزيد
منها اذا ما استمرت الحكومه في عدم
استجابه همم استجابتها لمطالب رفع الاجور
لعده قطاعات وخاصه في ما يتعلق بقطاع همم
القطارات وايضا الممرضين هناك سلسله
اضرابات متوقع بدايه من الشهر المقبل مثلا
بالنسبه للقطارات ستخوض همم اضرابات على
مدى خمسه ايام وبالتالي هذا سيحدث
اضطرابات كبيره ولا ربما ستمتد هذه
الاضرابات في قطاع النقل يشمل جميع همم
القطاع في المملكه المتحده بالاضافه الى
الممرضين وايضا اطقم الاسعاف الى ذلك هناك
مؤسسات حكوميه تتعلق بصيانه طرق السريعه
وايضا ما يتعلق همم
بالمشرفين على همم اختبارات القياده
وبالتالي همم لا مؤشره على هذه الاضطرابات
وبالطبع سنه كئيبه للجميع وخاصه لهؤلاء
الذين لم يتلقوا زياده رواتب تتماشى مع
التحديات الاقتصاديه هذا فبريطانيا ماذا
عن فرنسا ومن هناك حسين فياض قنيبر حسين
مساء الخير في الواقع الاضرابات التي
توسعت على قطاعات معينه والتي دعت اليها
بالاضافه الى التظاهرات بعض الاحزاب وبعد
النقابات خلال الشهرين الماضيين عادل
ستصبح اضرابات تظاهرات واسعه النطاق تدعو
اليها معظم الاحزاب ومعظم النقابات خلال
الشهر المقبل بالتزامن مع مناقشه النواب
لمشروع قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد الحكومه
تريد جعله عند مستوى الاربعه ستين عاما اي
سن التقاعد مقابل اثنين و60 عاما حاليا
سيشهد الشهر المقبل التحركات التاليه في
العاشر منه سيكون هناك اضراب في قطاع
النقل في السابع عشر سيكون هناك اضراب في
قطاع التعليم وايضا في النصف الثاني من
الشهر المقبل سيكون هناك اضراب في قطاع
الطاقه وستدعو حركه فرنسا العصيه من اقصى
اليسار لدعامه وط
بعض يوم الحادي والعشرين من الشهر المقبل
بالاضافه الى ان كل النقابات اتفقت على
يوم تحرك في النصف الثاني من الشهر المقبل
كل ذلك هدفه الدعوه الى رفع الرواتب ووضع
حد الارتفاع الاسعار خصوصا الاسعار المواد
الاساسيه وفرض ضرائب على الاغنياء وشركات
التي تحقق ارباحا كبيرا هو ايضا تخفيض
قيمه الضريبه الضريبه على القيمه المضافه
فيما يتعلق باسعار المواد الاساسيه وخصوصا
الطاقه واخيرا المطالبه بجعل سن التقاعد
60 عاما وعدم رفعه الى ال 64 عاما هو
حاليا 62 عاما فقط
عادل نعم حسين يعني بقي عندي دقيقه بينك
وبين زاره اليوم الاخيره الذي يفصلنا عن
العام الجديد الفرنسيون كيف ينظرون الى
هذا العمل الذي سياتي
قلقون جدا من مواصله ارتفاع الاسعار مثال
سريع اسعار الكهرباء ارتفعت من خمسه و 80
يوما للمجاوارات في الساعه في الصيف العام
2021 الى 1000 يورو للميجاوات في الساعه 5
هذا العام 2022 ويتوقعون الدفاع اسعار
الكهرباء والغاز ايضا الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
خشيه كبيره عادل من ان لا يستطيع
المواطنون البريطانيون دفع فواتير
الكهرباء والغاز خاصه وان تم تخفيض سقف
الدعم الحكومي ليصل الى ثلاثه الاف جنيه
هذا متوسط ولكن قل ما استهلكت اكثر قل ما
ستدفع يعني مبلغ كبير مقارنه
ان شاء الله العام الجديد يكون عام خير
عليكم وعلى كل من يشاهدناه بالتاكيد شكرا
جزيلا لحسين خنيبر مراسل العربيه من باريس
وكذلك مصطفى زارو مراسل العربيه من لندن
[موسيقى]
في نهايه اخبار الساعه نتوقف معكم مع ابرز
مشاهد العام في 2011
[موسيقى]
فادي
اهم
سبب ستار سبورت
[موسيقى]
نهايه الناس تذكرهم بابراز العناوين
قيود الطالبان ضد المراه تهدد بكثره كارثه
في افغانستان الملايين يواجهون خطر البقاء
والتعليم على شفا الانهيار
بعد لقاء موسكو الى بوادر التقارب التركي
مع دمشق هديه ثمينه في شمال السوريه ووعود
على الطريق
وفاته اسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه بيليه
عن 82 عاما بسرطان القولون
قلق فلسطينيه من حكومتنا ياهو اليمنيه
اولوياتها توسيع الاستيطان التهجير واعاده
الاغتيالات
[موسيقى]
العالمي والدعماء 2022 بازمه طاقه غير
مسبوقه وارتفاعها كبير في الاسعار هل
ستفرغه 2023 الجيوب ايضا
ان شاء الله سنه خير كل عام وانتم بخير في
امان الكريم
[موسيقى]